the horses really do help you with
regression once you own a horse and out
that's all your mind is always having
fun
my name is Shai here and I'm a concrete
I would
I first got on a horse after I turned 10
Hey
I was young so I was like I like that
horse I thought it was cool horses I
remember just like us
me and shadow had to combine our tempers
and work together because she's the walk
wire while I was running but though
people off and I just always just get
back on her just ahead of patience when
I ride people actually give me like
drops and they actually be applauding me
the hood guys and everything
maybe accident can I ride you want to
trade people like what a stable started
about ten years ago it gave me something
to do something to keep the kids busy
with keep them occupied from running a
street get in trouble
and Southwest Philadelphia it's a lot of
sense was killing and I try to give kids
something to get away from stuff like
that and when they start learning with
the animals they kind of calm down
because they teach it and they learn it
and it helps them out a lot Hey finally
since community's crazy I don't lost a
brother uncle I lost a lot of friends
but when I work with the horses like a
type of therapy I can have fun and not
worry about everything else that's going
on around yeah I would have never met
Malik
instead of riding horses I probably
would have been doing stuff that I was
supposed to be doing getting in trouble
once you get to running and having fun
it seemed like all that is forgotten